this morning we're hearing from the
parents of a 20 year old student who
died after an alleged hazing
at ohio's bowling green state university
his name was stone faults he attended an
off-campus initiation right for the
pi kappa alpha fraternity back in march
a group of fraternity members faces
criminal charges ranging from
involuntary manslaughter to tampering
with the evidence
mola languages in bowling green with
more on this story mola it just sounds
so senseless to me what exactly happened
here
well gail prosecutors say after that
fraternity initiation event that you
mentioned
fultz's blood alcohol level was .35 that
is more than
four times over the legal driving limit
and what prosecutors describe
is catastrophic now fultz's parents told
us that these charges are just their
first step
towards changing frat culture for those
who didn't know stone
who was he tell me about him he was the
most caring individual
any new person he met he was always kind
of
always outgoing with them you know he
asked about them he always
he wanted to know you know their life
story and
he just was a generous individual who
was always looking out for others
sherry and corey fultz last spoke to
their 20 year old son
stone shortly before a fraternity
initiation ritual held in march
he had said to me yeah we have a
drinking ritual that we have to go to
and i'm not looking forward to it
i don't want to do it my response is
then don't and he said that's rituals
you have to do them and that's how it is
with every fraternity
of course i i never thought in a million
years that it was
that type of ritual fultz consumed the
equivalent of about
17 shots of alcohol one of the men
charged dropped him off at home
prosecutors say fultz's roommate found
him
and called 9-1-1 do you see his chest
rising up and down
no not right now okay he's blue
yeah okay then he there's a good chance
he's not breathing fultz was taken to
the hospital
and placed on life support he died three
days later
we have two other children we don't have
time to grieve
we have to stay strong prosecutors
indicted eight
current and former bowling green state
university students
on a total of 17 felonies and 25
misdemeanors
obviously we can't bring stone back but
we are appreciative that they're headed
in the right direction to bring peace
and
justice for stone what does peace and
justice look like
to us it's to you know hold those
accountable for what has happened
because
you know the fraternity hazing that's
going on it's unacceptable
it truly is abuse it's the parent's
worst nightmare
fulton's parents are pushing for a bill
here in the state of ohio that would
make
fraternity hazing a felony and hopefully
end it once and for all
meanwhile the fraternity has been
permanently banned from campus and
prosecutors say
even more charges could be coming tony
mola thank you very much it is a
parent's worst nightmare oh yes it makes
me think guys of the piazza case you
remember
jim and evelyn piazza about their son
timothy where this is happening
you know we keep reporting on it we keep
telling it but these kids feel such peer
pressure to go it yes to do it here's
stone's telling his
family i don't want to do it it's not
okay
losing your child under any circumstance
is horrible to lose your son this way i
can't even imagine that it's so
preventable
so unnecessary yes exactly the word yep
all right
mola thanks again so sorry